and I'll tell you I've been married now
for almost 20 years and this is the
absolute best time of our marriage and I
and I will tell you it's 100 because of
quarantine I've been I traveled our
whole marriage you know and so we'd
never had that much concentrated time
together and it was it was amazing and
we had conversations that like our life
feel like early relationship
conversations but we finally had them
like she asked me who my hall pass was
has anyone had that conversation with
their spouse about who their home who's
your home address you nodded your head
Jared Leto who's yours he's like Jared
little yeah
you guys watch Batman she's like this is
amazing he's like I know
my wife asked me she said who
is your hall pass and I said you should
go first
and she said my hall passes Brad Pitt
by the way for me it's a great choice
yeah dude I I to me there's no bad pit
either pick a movie Legends of the Fall
pit money ball pit fight ball pit it's
all good pit there's no bad pit right no
bad pit and so I said it's a great
choice and she said who's yours I said
uh Janet who lives next door
[Music]
hey if I must shoot my shot it's gonna
be in reality everybody you know what
I'm saying
Brad Pitt is not [__] you I know that
for sure
but Friday night bottle of wine
I'm not gonna lie to you I think I got a
shot with Janet I really do